[موسيقى]
فالموقف في سوريا تكرر سواء عبر الجانب
الانسانيه والازمه عموما بان هناك مازقا
سياسيا وهناك استقطاب عميق جزء من ثمان
ذلك ان ازيد من 94% من السوريين يعيشون
تحت خط الفقر هذا ثمن باهض جدا اولا يدفعه
السوريون وثانيا اننا محدودون في التحرك
والاستجابه هناك مساعده انسانيه للسوريين
ولكن الى حد ما فبرنامج الامم المتحده
الامميه يعمل في سوريا لكن هناك عدد من
الحدود الصارمه التي سطرتها المجموعه
الدوليه والتي لا يمكننا التحرك خارجها
ليس مسموحا لنا المشاركه في اعاده التعمير
فنحن نساعد فقط في عمليات التعافيه
المبكره وفي بعض الاحيان علينا ان نتناقش
بشان الاولويات وان نختار بين ان ندعم
عمليات التعافيه المبكر او بالس ماح الى
النساء بالتنقل داخل وبين القرى والمدن او
ان نشارك في اعاده تعمير تلك المناطق هكذا
وفي بعض الاحيان كيف تعقد التوترات
السياسيه عملنا ولكن في النهايه نحن
مؤمنون بانه وحتى نستمر باداء اعمالنا في
سوريا فان التنميه ينبغي ان تكون جزءا من
ذلك
[موسيقى]
كل شخص يرغب بالعوده الى دياره لكن اذا لم
يكن لديك مدرسه او كهرباء او ما او
الاساسيات التي تسمح لك بالعيش فانك لن
تعود برنامج الامم المتحده الاملائيه
وقتها بدعم من الاسره الدوليه والسلطات
المحليه ايضا وخاصه نجح في احداث فريق
هائل وهذا هو تحديدا ما نرغب بجلبه
للمناطق التي تعيش ازمات ونعمل الان في
المنطقه في دول مثل اليمن وفي لبنان الذي
يعيش وضع اقتصاديا حرجا للغايه اين نساعد
مؤسسات الدوله هناك على الحفاظ على
وظائفها الاساسيه بما يساعدها على اداء
مهامها في العراق نجحنا بعد النزاع الاول
في احداث الفارق وامنوا ان يستمر البرنامج
في العمل مع الدول المجاوره التي ترغب
برؤيه جيرانها لا تعاني من مثل هذه الظروف
نحن شريك موثوق وكفر نعمل تحت مظله الامم
المتحده على ضمان ان تعاقد الاوضاع اكثر
[موسيقى]